secretary Rex Tillerson with only hours
remaining leading the State Department
said goodbye warning of unresolved
challenges in Syria and with China and
Russia Russia must assess carefully as
to how its actions are in the best
interest of the Russian people and of
the world more broadly continuing on
their current trajectory is likely to
lead to greater isolation on their part
Tillerson disagreed with President Trump
on several issues Russia Qatar the Paris
climate agreement and rhetoric I don't
believe anyone doubts the American
people's values or the commitment of the
American government or the government's
agencies to advancing those values and
defending those values and and the
president's values the president speaks
for himself Chris and primarily the Iran
nuclear agreement this morning the
president cited it is a reason for the
changed state and in August Tillerson
publicly acknowledged they disagreed on
Iran yeah and I have differences of
views on things like jcpoa and how we
should use it we have differences of but
I think if we're not having those
differences I'm not sure I'm serving him
Tillerson has lobbied the administration
to remain in the Iran nuclear agreement
his State Department's been negotiating
changes to Iran policy with European
allies to keep the u.s. in the deal
Tillerson 'he's nominated successor CIA
director Mike Pompeo is a longtime
critic of the agreement missile tests
the activity of the Shia militias in
Iraq their work alongside Lebanese
Hezbollah in Syria and in Lebanon their
malign activity all around the world has
dramatically increased since this deal
was struck speculation peaked this fall
that the president would fire Tillerson
he stayed and after months aids it
stayed assumed Tillerson would remain
congressional aides say relations with
Congress improved he traveled more and
even spent a little more time with the
press do you believe there are still
people in the White House who don't want
you to be Secretary of State I have no
idea
secretary Tillerson closed here thanking
his senior staff and those he worked
with across the State Department in
other departments especially the
military the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff and the defense
secretary one name omitted from his list
of thank-yous Brett the president's